the first movie I think that I really  remember seeing was I think Robin Hood  the Errol Flynn robin hood movie because  I just remember loving the whole way of  being a swashbuckler and that that how  that made me feel and so that's the  movie that comes to mind in terms of the  first one I know it's followed right  right away by The Wizard of Oz because  the wizard of oz probably like for  everybody is that movie that that  actually said the message that we've all  heard for our entire lifetimes which is  there's home and there's no place like  home but there's also some place else  and that other place is magical and in  Technicolor and a place of dreams and  demons and and so that's the one that I  think Robin Hood is a part of but in  terms of the first movie ever was  probably Robin Hood with Errol Flynn